the fastest way to grow your business to
accomplish any goal that you're after is
to model success find someone who's
already done what you're trying to do
look at how they did it and apply it to
whatever you're trying to do hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help so today i'm
answering a question from one of my
readers Raymond who wrote in to say how
can I use modeling techniques thanks to
the question Raymond there are two ways
to do it that I love that work extremely
well the first is look at companies in
your industry and look at how they got
started so for me I had a software
business it was biotech software there
wasn't a huge biotech software company
so i looked at software in general and
looked at Microsoft looked at how they
got started I don't care how Bill Gates
makes an action million dollars now how
do you go from zero to one that's what I
wanted to learn that's what I wanted to
apply to my business the bigger the
company is the easier it is to find out
their stories and look at what they were
doing when they were your size how did
they get their first customers how did
they get there first partners how did
they recruit employees how did they get
in the media how did they get investors
whatever problem you're facing right now
look at how they solved it for me I
wanted business growth and the way
Microsoft did it was through
partnerships they partnered up with
people who already had their success
they had their target market and they
just partnered up with those companies
so we did the same thing and these
companies helped drag us along they
saved this huge amount of time in
getting to market because they already
had the connections we applied that to
our business and our business took off
so whatever your business is look at who
the biggest names are and look at their
early days and how they got started
apply it to your business as well the
second kind of company that I like to
look at I call aspirational mentors
these are people who you look up to but
they have nothing to do with your
business so maybe really like Richard
Branson maybe really like Oprah Winfrey
maybe really like Donald Trump whoever
it is look at Richard Branson how we got
started how he promotes his business
even though you may have nothing to do
with the airline business or the music
industry that he was involved in you're
doing something completely different you
can still learn from his success
how he markets his business those
lessons are still applicable to your
company you just have to find out how to
do it so look at these guys look at how
they got started read their biographies
again you can't compete with virgin
right now you can't look at what they're
doing right now because it's way too big
look at how Richard Branson got started
read his biography look online there's
tons of stories we have a lot on our
website as well look at how they got
started and grew their business and
there's lessons there that you can learn
and directly apply to your company again
the fastest way to accomplish any goal
to grow your business or whatever it is
business or personal the fastest way to
accomplish it is to model success
instead of trying to figure everything
out yourself find someone who's already
done it and apply their lessons to what
you're going through right now it'll
make a huge impact on your business and
your life I guarantee it for those of
you watching if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below if you
have a comment or if you agree with what
I say or disagree for some reason feel
free to leave it in the comment section
below I always read those I always check
them out thank you great question
Raymond and I'll see you guys on the
next episode
you